was up its samuel l.jackson and I'm
going undercover on the internet it's
actually my mother's twitch I did 70
little Jackson any chance you could
record yourself saying
back away [ __ ] to play every
time I open my snack cupboard no [ __ ]
way
BAM scrolling right along what role do
you get asked about more Star Wars Pulp
Fiction or incredible getting better
Graham I've actually been off for a
couple of weeks and I've been working on
my swing almost down to my old handicap
we want to talk about what that is but
low single digits all these Hollywood
sequels and spin-offs and all I want to
know is where snakes on a train I don't
know I don't know where snakes on train
is um be glad to watch it I do it snakes
would open up does samuel l.jackson
really like anime yeah
enter howell samuel l.jackson able to
get a role as a voice actor any
incredible brad says when he was writing
this he had the particular actors that
he got in mind and he actually got 95%
of the people that he thought of when he
was writing just lucky I guess
who wins in a battle between every
single character ever played by samuel
l.jackson mace windu kicked everybody's
ass he's a Jedi what is the line from
pulp fiction that samuel l.jackson uses
where he includes the word smite smite
no [ __ ] clue strike down upon thee
with great vengeance and furious thank
you no I don't know probably
wearing a car when you know pissed off
with John about the brains I don't know
but it's pop fiction nerds
I am DB trivia wasn't uh sure dr. Martin
Luther King jr. yes I was the general
was held on campus Morehouse College I
was a student a students to volunteer to
help people find their ways one place to
another I did that as opposed to other
actors and actresses he enjoys watching
his own he loved looking right at it hey
Joey my movies my favorite movie in mine
to watch long kiss goodnight yeah you
may not believe it but it's actually me
12th grade he played the French horn and
trouble in school orchestra also played
the flute and sometimes piccolo no
childhood he had a stuttering problem
yes I did while he eventually learned to
pretend to be other people who didn't
stutter and use the word [ __ ] as
an information word he still has days
where he studies I do some days it's you
know if sentences that begin with W some
day it's a same M days and in there
sometimes it's s days but I just say
[ __ ] is done well others my new
favorite thing is adding smiles to
pictures of samuel l.jackson sorry those
are not my teeth next yahoo answers what
guitar was played by samuel l.jackson in
Black Snake Moan it was actually a gift
in the Academy Award gift bag that year
to give them with gold frets and you
know awesome officially you to Game of
Thrones please Cass Samuel Jackson he
can do an English accent right to pay me
enough
Oh stead more Twitter does my dog what
bike Samuel Jackson
no I mean make his whole face brown
we'll talk about is there better
supporting from performance to Samuel
Jackson in Pulp Fiction in the last 30
years I find that generally hard to
believe and what makes you think it was
the [ __ ] supporting them more there's
an argument to be made that I was a lead
acting role beginning of the film into
the cell kind of book in the movie I
might just be a lead actor I might
remember when samuel l.jackson first got
on twitter and he tweeted at everyone to
ask him follow us to follow him that was
a fun time I was stupid I had no idea
what I was doing on Twitter when I
joined Twitter on Fallon one night I
think the first tweet I ever tweeted was
kind of [ __ ] say [ __ ] on here
and I didn't know how you got followers
I thought you did have to ask or ball
followers from people or ask people to
tell people you know that guy's got a
Twitter follow him so that was stupid hi
digging handball hope you learned the
rule since London what what all right
who knows the rule in this handball [ __ ]
it's fast and furious though oh that was
my tweet from the Olympics and yeah
what's that game no I don't know rules
I still like watching it you know people
running around throwing balls and trying
to throw them in a net
kind of fun they know it was an Olympic
sport though some more Korra can have to
to use swords in their roles all their
own in a real sword fight X am Jackson
mace windu I don't know exactly what
that means in terms of what you want to
know that was the time when you went to
action school fencing was a part of your
requirement so a lot of us did that but
majority of fighting is choreographed
the lightsaber battles takes a long time
to learn those or it did when I was
doing the last one I had with the
Emperor was 99 moves through three rooms
backwards from me so two weeks of
sneakers and shorts two weeks in Boots
another week and Jedi robe boots light
saber before we actually shot it so it's
pretty intense
how many movies are set my little guys
have been in I have no idea I don't keep
count I just keep getting up going to
work blast that more Wikipedia Jackson
has a clause in his film contracts that
allows him to play golf during film
shoots yes I do and they pay for work I
hope I've answered your questions and I
answered them sufficient if I didn't you
know get